with a story from Metro News West
Virginia
explosive devices reported at two
locations in Bluefield
there were no injuries of the discovery
of two explosive devices in Bluefield on
Monday morning West Virginia State
Police the Bluefield police department
and other law enforcement responded to a
call at the federal courthouse in
downtown Bluefield around 9 40 AM
officers evacuated all people from the
building and and an adjacent Department
building as they dealt with the device
apparently they detonated police Health
fire in the hole before a loud boom was
heard it was destroyed around 11 40
inside the federal building an explosion
was heard from the building another
device was found at I believe it's down
here
Westminster Presbyterian Church in
Bluefield West Virginia bomb squad has
arrived so uh the reason I thought this
was you know what this this story caught
my eye and it's not really getting a lot
of attention is someone pointed a bomb
at a federal courthouse
I mean we saw in in 2020 the riots with
the far left they were attacking the
federal courthouse in Portland
and then I saw was West Virginia and
West Virginia's Maga country you know
it's it's the second most Trump
supporting state in the United States so
I wondered who or why would someone do
this entirely possible it's an isolated
incident pertaining to local matters and
it's only getting national attention
because of the tensions and the
conflicts been happening at the federal
level or with the FBI for instance so we
don't know for sure
uh entirely could be local conflict
or it could be I mean I'll just I'll
just throw out to you guys what
political ideology would attack a
federal courthouse in a church
well I've been on high alert since
Dugan's daughter we might talk about
this more later that's the next one
we're getting okay his daughter was
killed in a car bomb so there's this
bombing theme in the last five days all
of a sudden I'm very concerned about
false Flags this could have been someone
from another country that wants to
instill agitation in the in the people's
minds I and that it's a church and a
courthouse like I think two different
buildings about a mile apart yeah like
you don't have far right religious
zealots bombing churches ever really I
mean so that doesn't make it doesn't
seem like uh I am very hesitant to start
blaming groups or ideologies for this
because it could be anybody that wants
to see chaos in the United States it
could be doing stuff fog of War man Yuri
besmanov yeah I I remember in the 1970s
there were a lot of environmentalists
extremists who bombed Federal buildings
or uh Federal lands the there is a
suspect in custody he's uh his name's
Dean fabler he's 50 years old there's
not I haven't had a chance to look into
him too intensely I mean there is the
Instinct and I hesitate to tie it to any
specific group although it's incredibly
disruptive
um but there's also a chance someone had
something personal I was saying before
the show that I wonder what uh what was
on the docket in the courthouse that day
um and we looked it up the church and
the uh Federal Building are about a mile
apart so there's a question of like why
those two places because this is Roe v
Wade I mean there's anything church or
he knows a lawyer who was practicing and
he's mad at the priest down the street
like it's very hard to tell without a
ton of information
first and foremost the most important
thing it it's it's it's Small Town West
Virginia so strong possibility
guy you know the priest and his neighbor
got into a fight they have a court
hearing for some reason I don't know
it's a federal court so that doesn't
make sense actually yeah there's no
reason why a local dispute would go to a
federal court it could be someone from
outside the state way to dispute this
guy and it was being sued interstate so
it's Federal it's possible but I gotta
say
the memes I also I see all right now are
Roe v Wade the federal courts the
Supreme Court the federal court of this
country the big one
why would someone go after a church in a
federal court Simple Solution hypothesis
not saying we have any evidence of this
is is left wing yeah I mean it's
typically not
well I I don't know I don't know it's
it's scary stuff considering the
escalation we've seen around the world
and the United States my first thought
was when uh the news broke there was a
federal courthouse that they were going
to start saying it was Trump supporters
because of the FBI because they're going
after Trump and because this judge this
this uh this federal judge in Florida is
a Epstein lawyer I don't know if you're
familiar with this guy right yeah I mean
you know I've read the stories yeah and
so I was thinking like maybe this is you
know like that guy in Ohio but then they
found okay then they said we found we
found one at a church and I'm like okay
now that doesn't make sense like a trump
supporter is not going to put a bomb at
a church that's that they donate to the
church you know if they ever do anything
right and so then I saw you know I saw
these memes on Facebook and they're
calling it November they're saying
rovember Roe v Wade November go out and
vote in November Democrats Roe v Wade
the federal courts the churches the
religious people and I'm wondering if
this is just more likely to be at the
very least not saying we have evidence
but left-wing radicalization and and
attacks
why would it happen in literal manga
country though it's just it's just weird
I mean it's a sign of uh disruption West
Virginia is such an interesting State
because it does have such a Dem tie to
the Democratic party it was a democratic
stronghold for a long long time and so I
think that native West Virginians while
they are often manga supporting
um it's a more complex State than people
give it credit for because they
ultimately like every county in the
state went for Trump I do say like it's
very hard to tell I wouldn't be
surprised at all if this had left-wing
ties and again I would really like to
know what was going on in the courthouse
today the church is what's interesting
to me because it feels more personal
again a mile away a 20-minute walk that
means that you could have probably I
mean it's West Virginia there are
probably four other churches within the
vicinity why the Presbyterian one why
that one specifically and again that
goes back to it being specific to that
Community you want to look you can look
yeah no I mean this is the thing I can't
reconcile right a local dispute with a
local church but a federal courthouse
there wouldn't be a suit at the federal
courthouse maybe uh the somewhere the
church ratted out a guy and it's it's a
criminal matter I honestly don't know
they said that the suspect who's in
custody is going to undergo evaluation
so they might be arguing that there's
some sort of psychological disturbance
like but again this is putting a bomb
anywhere is a functioning bomb they had
to detonate this with them and they
didn't go in and say like oh this
doesn't work or it's fake like they had
to destroy it is there knowledge about
what the explosive was sometimes that
can help you discern who did it they
didn't say I haven't seen anything but
obviously there's a reason why I bring
this up
Civil War
right is this uh you know how how old
are you uh Joe can I ask I am you can
ask you don't seem to ask
I'm 43 years old
okay you look so much 79 baby
yeah what month
I was born in December okay April I was
talking to a guy who was in his 60s and
he said that he was uh just a couple of
years shy of getting drafted into
Vietnam and then I said so you saw the
news reports about The Weather
Underground and he's like oh yeah and
then I was like is it worse now or was
it worse than he says way worse now he
can't believe it that's the media a lot
of it is because of the media because
one bomb in central you know West
Virginia now is global note like
notoriety whereas in the 70s it was like
good luck if you read about in the paper
the next day maybe it was more Regional
and that could be it and that's one of
the things he pointed out he said the
issue is that everything's instantaneous
these days you know back then something
would happen it would take a while for
people to find out about it and react to
it whether that's an escalation or just
you know generally learning about it and
so I think that's the important point in
the 70s with the Weather Underground
something happens when did you learn it
happened right three days later maybe it
happens on a Friday you don't watch the
news until Monday and then Monday news
report comes out you're like huh today
it's the moment it happens the moment
this story hit
like I'm I'm seeing it I mean grant that
it's my job but for people who are on
Twitter you're learning about it right
away I think that actually does mean
it's worse though you know why
if it took a week I mean you go back to
the revolutionary period if it took a
month or two months for someone in a
different state to find out that someone
got shot in a different state they could
not react to it or escalate because they
didn't know it happened but now with
social media and with instant
Communications the moment it happens
you're you see a protest right like you
get a video of a dude being beaten by
cops hour later black lives matter is
out on the street protesting that wasn't
that would be possible without the
internet without cell phones before
before even before
um
even when we had cell phones that
wouldn't have happened it was only after
the iPhone made it possible for people
to pull up Facebook and see Community
organizing instantly did we start seeing
that kind of phenomenon phenomenon so it
could be 2007.
some cop beats a guy
protests don't show up until the next
day because people go home get on the
computer then learn about it then show
up the next day today mass texts go out
so I'm wondering if are tolerance for
violence is going down and it's not
necessarily I think violence is getting
is is up obviously murders are way up
but I'm wondering if relative to
political conflicts it's not as much
violence that will trigger a civil war
Civil conflict or something like that I
I it's very interesting conversation I
think it's it's I'm calloused to this
stuff I've become calloused uh I see it
it doesn't hurt as bad I don't
immediately believe that guy's the
villain because I think I saw him punch
him like I don't know what's going on
but the downside is when you're
calloused you don't you can't really
feel I can't feel it it's not it's not
making me snap to attention maybe like
it should be
um the downside is people are going to
go nuts faster the upside is people can
mobilize faster if there's a real
emergency like a some sort of flood or
whatever there are just to tie this up
10 Close 10 churches closer to the
courthouse than the Westminster
Presbyterian Church which is actually a
little bit far like interesting farther
away uh sorry I didn't mean it sounds
like some local no that's a good point
though but why a federal courthouse
maybe somebody who works at the
courthouse or just locally to be
disruptive I mean yeah I think you're
still right that it could be tied to
ideology and they know they have access
to a federal courthouse in their Town
um earlier I pitched like well we have
to see how far the church is because
what if the church is outside so when
you evacuate the building people come
outside and it's even more of a
dangerous situation
um I think
when we just to tie it up back to what
you're saying with the new cycle I think
that these moments that feel like
breaking news you know for us because
we're watching the news it is really
interesting and for some people they'll
remember it but they won't start to pay
attention until there's a pattern until
there's another federal courthouse in
another small town in another part of
America and then it will start to seem
like oh wait is something going on and
at that point we really have to ask
ourselves like are we too late are we
missing something that's really
significant that's going on one of the
mistakes people make is when you hear
stories about small rural towns being
you know targeted in this way for
whatever this was
they say well it's probably not
political because why would they come to
this small town and it's like okay you
know that's one way to think about it
but we have seen antifa go to small
towns we have seen riots in small towns
and the the idea behind that is
in order to inflict maximum Terror if
you're engaged in political violence you
have to go to small towns because people
feel safe when they're far away from the
cities if the riots and the attacks are
happening in small towns so that was the
logic around why far-left extremists
were going to these towns it's the logic
behind why a terrorist would attack a
small town to make sure that everyone
feels terrified of it
I mean either way this looks like Terror
it was at a courthouse I think that
instantly qualifies it a church
possibly but a church could be I suppose
both could be personal like a guy didn't
like an employee at either of these
places but who knows thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there